he's one angry prince after returning
home from boarding school this errand
waiting finds his relatives have carved
up the kingdom between them
the aim of royal revolt is to help the
young prince went back what is
rightfully his the game was developed by
Flair games together with its subsidiary
kena Flair just days after hitting App
Store's the game was downloaded by more
than a million gamers worldwide now it's
on the shortlist for a prize at this
year's German Game Awards 1 million
downloads sounds like an awful lot but
you shouldn't forget that there are
billions of smartphones out there but
it's a respectable figure and many games
never manage to get close to that amount
nevertheless we're aiming for more a lot
more classic hair sting is no stranger
to success the 33 year old founded his
first computer game studio ten years ago
and turned it into one of the world's
biggest games publishers a year and a
half ago he set up Flair games in
Karlsruhe the company's team of 50
developers turns creative ideas into
popular mobile games we've got a lot of
veterans from the gaming industry here
some come from classic PC games and from
the online games branch some of them
have been around for more than 10 years
it's definitely the sort of company that
isn't very common here in Germany we
managed because we have many well-known
people from the gaming industry here and
are attracting talented young people who
can help support our team one veteran
game designer is Ralph Martian shik as
royal revolts lead artist
was his job to oversee the artistic
development of the game together with
Israeli animator enough dari
the game's lead character has been kept
simple what at first glance might look
like a game designed for children is
actually targeted towards grown-up
gamers you have to conquer one castle
after another in order to reclaim the
kingdom once you start you realize
there's a lot more to it than meets the
eye but generally it's easy for players
to get into the game and play it it has
a certain depth to it
but you'll be finished with your mission
after three to four minutes sync and do
other things and then come back to the
game later sales of mobile games doubled
in Germany between 2011 and 2012 tiny
wings is one of the most popular the
idea behind it is simple but it's been a
big success keep it simple with a
principle followed by the developers of
word wonder it's also in the running for
a prize at this year's German Game
Awards the precursor to today's mobile
games can be seen here at Berlin's
computer game museum this pocket soccer
game from Mattel was way ahead of its
time when it hit stores back in 1976
Nokia released snake more than 20 years
later it was the first game that could
be played on a cell phone the mobile
speed on mobile games got an incredible
boost thanks to smartphones they were
first intended to just make calls but
now they are so powerful that they are
perfectly suited to playing games on and
could be permanently hooked up to the
web that enables multiplayer gaming
anytime and anywhere this has been made
possible by the advent of the smartphone
and has led to the expansion of the
whole mobile game sector
but I school being skiing a few the
programmers at Flair games love to play
games whether they're board games or of
the mobile variety at the moment they're
working on six new mobile games
two of them are slated to hit App
Store's in May the developers are
keeping them closely under wraps but
have already disclosed that they'll be
strategy games